good evening and welcome to fox news
prime time i am brian kilmeade but brett
gave that away
another day another flurry of executive
orders this time joe biden setting his
sights on the cratering economy
kinda he says we have a moral obligation
to get people back to work
we can not will not let people go hungry
we cannot let people be evicted because
of nothing they did themselves
they cannot watch people lose their jobs
and we have to act we have to act now
this is an economic imperative a growing
economic consensus that we must act
decisively and boldly
to grow the economy for all americans
not just for tomorrow but in the future
sounds good right the president claims
to be taking decisive action during
these dark days of the pandemic
which is true but it's not to help you
your family your neighbor your town
he's fulfilling campaign promises that i
contend won't add a single
job but will erase plenty of jobs
yesterday with a stroke of a bend
biden killed the keystone xl pipeline
and
an estimated 71 000 jobs many of them
good paying union jobs he doubted
on the campaign trail he was all about
unions remember the move will likely
erase energy costs raise them up i
should say
and hurt our relationship with canada
more on that later in the show
he also halted the southern border wall
already paid for a cost of billions of
dollars
at least five thousand jobs i think a
lot more but that's not all
today he mandated a federal minimum wage
of 15 a move that
nonpartisan cbo the congressional budget
office says will eliminate 3.7 million
jobs how does this make sense
the increased cost of labor is also
guaranteed to hurt small businesses
that are hanging on by a thread during
the pandemic
sadly it's not the time to give people a
raise because all boats rise right
what kind of president does this
unilaterally on day one and day two
without even taking the time to explain
his actions he signs he mumbles he
closes and we move
i'll tell you one that's more concerned
about pandering to the far left
because he has got a base of american
workers who are counting on him and his
left-wing policies
so for anyone who's about to lose their
job because of these executive
orders do not worry the biden
administration has some advice for you
it's a little different but let's listen
together
so for those workers the answer is
somebody else will get a job
the answer is that we are very eager to
see those workers continue to be
employed in
good paying union jobs even if they
might be different ones
here with reaction republican
congressman dan crenshaw of texas
congressman i i even just texted you
i'm so disappointed what's happened over
the last two or three days
there's no conversation there's no given
give and take there's no
kevin mccarthy let's do something
together here
it was a great speech perhaps but is
there is there any indication there's
any going to be any bipartisanship
and this is going to help the economy
now they're going to keep talking about
unity but they don't want to unify
behind anything that the american
working class might actually want
so you couldn't have said it better than
what you just said brian you know you
talked about
cancelling the keystone pipeline that's
tens of thousands of union
jobs indian jobs by the way that pay a
lot better than jobs for say solar and
wind
okay on average twenty thousand dollars
better pay for oil and gas jobs than for
solar and wind and by the way most of
those jobs for solar and wind
manufacturing
those are in china okay so that's what
pete buda judge is talking about when he
says other jobs he's not talking about
good paying american jobs
and they need to confront this fact and
they need to confront the fact that when
you
drastically raise the minimum wage all
of a sudden to 15
an hour you're going to cut you're going
to cut out millions of jobs across
america that's not according to me
that's going to the congressional budget
office
i've got small businesses in my district
begging me to do something about this
you can't let them
do this they say we will we will
immediately lose our business we're
already hanging on by a thread
so listen here's what it comes down to
if you're going to claim
that you're the party of the american
working class you actually have to
support
working all right that's a requirement
to be a working-class party and they
just won't do that we had a meeting
today
and we were saying can you name one
policy that was intentionally put out
there by the trump administration that
would eliminate jobs
all he cared about was jobs to the
detriment maybe of other things
in fact when you hear what canada's
perspective is they are
enraged as much as there happened to
have a democratic president and perhaps
donald trump out
they wanted this excel pipeline they
know it's clean they know it's passed
five separate environmental uh tests put
out by the obama administration
it was going to be american steel that
was made i want you to listen to the
alberta premier
his name is jason kenney on this what he
says
is a betrayal by joe biden
it's very frustrating that one of the
first acts of the new president was
i think to disrespect america's closest
friend
and ally canada evidently he's a liberal
in canada
dan it isn't just me and you talking
there's a lack of logic here
well also it's bad for the environment
all right and this is what the
the radical left doesn't really care
about the environment this is really
about the culture war to them
and for them fossil fuels are just evil
they don't know why they don't have to
tell you why you're stupid if you ask
why
but they just want to tell you they're
evil now the truth is when you build
pipelines to transport oil and gas
you're doing in a much cleaner and safer
way than say transporting it by truck or
by train
you're also you're also helping north
american energy independence which is
what our canadian friends are alluding
to
because if we're not producing it and if
we're not exporting cleaner
cleaner produced oil and cleaner
produced natural gas to the rest of the
world you know who is
russia venezuela iran saudi arabia and
they all do it dirtier than we do
so because of joe biden's policies
you're actually going to see an increase
in global emissions
okay you're going to see an increase in
manufacturing over in china the chinese
love this stuff because they love
selling us their solar panels and their
solar and their and their wind turbines
back here so that we clear our land
build a bunch of transmission lines
and screw up our energy independence
right this is what they love seeing they
love seeing the paris climate accords
going forward because they can keep
polluting
while our economy gets hurt even though
we're the ones even under the trump
administration
that reduced carbon emissions more than
any other country in the world
so this is actually bad for the
environment it's bad for the economy it
doesn't make any sense but it's good for
the radical left culture wars which is
really what they're after which is also
very interesting is we still get more
fossil fuels from canada than anybody
else we're their number one customer
and if you want to re-establish
relations with our neighbor joe biden's
first call is to justin trudeau and i
ask you dan just logically
if canada means that much to joe biden
we're your first international call is
to justin trudeau
why does this make sense can you clue me
in in washington
who is joe biden answering to
well i think we just did answer that
it's to the radical left it's it's the
culture warriors it's the post-modernist
progressives
okay again they want you to believe
certain things about america all right
they want you to believe it's evil
they want you to believe that you should
sacrifice but the chinese don't have to
they want you to believe that that your
job should be sacrificed for
other jobs that they prefer even though
they pay less and they're not good jobs
okay they want you to believe that the
7017 six commission
should be abolished because it teaches
you that america is too good right all
right and they would rather replace that
with the 1619 project this is who he's
listening to
pete buddha judge wasn't done there he
was asked about the highways and what
he's going to do is transportation
secretary because the former mayor of
south bend who is
average in every way shape or form said
this about our highways
so take get a pen ready i did not know
this also recognize
that at their worst misguided policies
and missed opportunities in
transportation
can reinforce racial and economic
inequality
by dividing or isolating neighborhoods
and undermining government's basic role
of empowering americans to thrive okay
uh we have racist highways now they are
they're they're very racist highways i
lived next to a highway
um i didn't realize that was a racist
highway i was living next to uh
look this this this is what happens when
when the progressive left takes over the
culture and takes over
the democrat party there's no more
liberals left in the democrat party no
more ideals of neutral application of
law
or neutral justice or universal
principles right all of these old
liberal principles that we used to agree
on are no longer agreed upon so they see
everything
through a social justice lens and
through critical race theory wherein
every
everything every problem that you see
and the only way to solve
said problem is to view it through a
racial lens and that's exactly what pete
beuta judge is doing right now
he's completely unqualified for this job
he's certainly bright served our country
but he's going to be transportation
secretary and is able to do late night
shows so it's an interesting time in
america that used to be a rarity
uh congressman dan crenshaw you can
officially start your weekend now but
knowing you it's going to be a working
weekend
as always great to have you great to be
with you brian thanks i really
appreciate you scrambling for us
meanwhile